that is definitely a claim it definitely
looks a lot better than a change this
looks by my beef and shrimp plate I
don't know if I've ever be in here
what's up guys I'm Q and today I'm gonna
be trying oshino you in the u.s. and
comparing it to Yoshino you're in Japan
Yoshino you actually originated in Japan
so I think this is gonna be an easy win
but who knows this should be interesting
to see my first time trying both so I'll
come with no bias this is gonna be
really interesting I don't know where to
start but since this is the closest to
me I'll stop here I'm pretty sure this
is the chicken teriyaki bowl looks
pretty standard there's some rice some
chicken on top some Sesame's like some
soy sauce sesame type of sauce
can't lie looks pretty solid looks like
that unhealthy healthy meal I mean off
the back this is smelling good
the rice is really sticky it definitely
looks a lot better than it tastes that
it looks really good it tastes okay like
the sauce doesn't really have like a
real flavor it's not bad but it looks
really good it tastes okay if I ate it I
would feel healthy eating this oh I
guess that's like a plus but that one
just really bought me so I made it to
Japan I'm in Tokyo right now at the nine
hours capsule hotel we might yes you
know you're right in front of me so
let's see what Japan s offer as far as
ocean area the cool thing already about
the Yoshino you in Japan is that it's
open 24 hours super jet lag so I woke up
at like 3 so right now it's 5 a.m. and
I'm like yeah oh he's just he if
something's open of course Yoshino yours
open at 3 a.m. 24 hours so I got a bunch
of stuff here I'm gonna start off on the
chicken curry I will say it did look way
better online
it okay Raj told me to put ginger -
ginger Oh had a request from the
producer in the back try with ginger
changes the game and they did last time
like I did the same thing last time
definitely oh that's pretty good I like
this this is already like a step above
us
yoshino you I bet it's kind of fair good
Yoshino yeah
originated here so of course gonna have
better food but live even quantum Lucy
this was good so this is the beef and
shrimp plate that like the shrimp from a
Panda Express and I should have good his
I the beef is really interesting it's
like diddly cut beef you know which was
like some sauce on here I think this was
missing is like the beef sauce on top
hopefully I'll taking notes yoshino yeah
beef and rice mmm huh so these need to
be mixed together that's pretty good
the meanings are sweet but still like
savory which is interesting for a beef
to be sweet but this is exactly that is
I will buy this the shrimp is high all
right well the pork and cheese this
looks fire all my dinners so we got some
pork we got some cheese that's some rice
imitating their - it's not surprising
but it might be right for the US on this
one this is the see now I know i
displace is open 24 hours because this
is like early morning hungover fool its
immediate really knew she would minded
to be a little cook more to be honest
but that's a planes and ears and type of
sauce this is good if somebody gave me
this is like a appetizer at like a fancy
restaurant I wasn't questioning anything
she's kind of afraid to go for this clam
chowder here's my question
why do she know you're serving clam
chowder and of all time started like the
New England clam what the hell are we
doing
Oh yucca smell this it tastes good
that's final dramatic but actually
that's really good damn it did a pretty
good job if you need some soup
yoshino you don't wait around go for it
[Music]
it's a very acquired taste not that
there's nothing little pieces in there
[Music]
chewy very like dummy it's pretty good
honestly I would take the damn chowder
over it is I don't want to may try to do
clam chowder
miso soup for the guy that several times
are in Japan it's pretty good to me it
kind of smells like tea I feel like miso
soup is served in almost every place
I've ever been to in your pan it's like
a state waiver for short I'm not expert
but I'm pretty sure that's about all
right so this is a six piece Asian
barbecue wings they basically like
boneless wings they smell really good
have uh some sesame seeds on top I can't
live this looks really good this is
something that I will order from
anywhere any restaurants mother oh yeah
dump it it's okay it's pretty good have
you got some extra money to just try
something
yes look this is the deal set
when I first saw it online and in person
I thought it was salmon hated be
ignorant but I don't know nothing about
food I just eat it I don't know if I've
ever eaten hill outside of uh sushi I
chopped the piece off am I chopped steak
that was actually pretty impressive
nothing laughs oh there we go for
someone who's never really eaten he'll
let me up there has like a fishy taste
but not too fishy struggling cutting his
deal with this with this chops they're
gonna show somebody in the comments
don't let me know how stupid I look I'm
trying to be like kind of quiet cuz it's
still like 5:00 a.m. this is like the
lounge waiting area so there's nobody
really out here outside of like the
reception it's not the best thing I have
a fire but 100% better
and everything I tried anyways I can't
really go wrong with spring rolls and I
think this sauce goes with him I don't
know kind of spring roses are but is
there more than one kind of spring roll
I'll do that a quick little dunk and
whatever sauce a hey pretty good I'm
gonna try without the sauce I'll go a
little low tangy
made me do like this this is good
I like these these are light but still
like the pub little greasy if it's
crunchy is probably good this don't need
the sauce I can eat like three or four
of these with like every meal that's um
kimchi not sure if you guys know who
Sean is but job of skin cheap so me and
trying to inch a really good Korean
barbecue spot in Koreatown in Los
Angeles man some really good kimchi
cumin is okay MT the gray side misses
well with like the beef and the pork and
cheese kind of offset offsets it you
know kind of like a palate cleanser
almost I was there this one isn't very
spicy which I like most kimchi's I'm out
of there very spicy and I'm not a fan so
technically I already had this rice and
beef but bias up I mean I think this
might actually be better than the last
one cuz the last we didn't have enough
meat to rice ratio just like some juice
on the rice you know I mean this beef is
cool though
move move oh listen the beef bowl
he won't pretty solid again this is beef
like I'm not sure what's going on here
I wish I had coal words to describe food
you know I'm saying right so it's good
it's bad what if I said it was pungent
is that good no oh got a request from
the producer in the back that's mom's
goodness
alright so I'll put some ginger on here
that's real tasty I want to take
somebody's up no smart man
if you go to Yoshino you you gotta try
the ginger on the food that's just some
extra to make it pop cuz that just
changed the game I promise you I was
like artists ok I'll talk nice about it
no it's fine now this is very familiar
into what we had from US beef and rice
it's up here they give you green onions
[Music]
but I am NOT a fan of soft-boiled eggs
or if they give it to me like that I'll
either like that whatever we'll see
this might be the first L oh I mean we
mix it in you never know it's very
similar to the mall back in the u.s. I
do meat is cut this aiming that way but
you can take that egg egg is creeping me
out a little bit somebody just take a
break on that but and I got the
cheesecake this is classy this is fancy
it came in a nice little box and I like
that here's the thing no - this is
Yoshino yeah originated in Japan where
the going on with this clam chowder in
this cheesecake excuse me for being
ignorant who was soft I'm not sure
that's a good thing or a bad thing but
it was like
quick and tasty whoa this is good
overall I'm pretty satisfied with the us
yoshino yeah
I didn't hear that many great things
about Yoshino yeah but that beef and
rice with the ginger on top fire
pro tip if you do go here put ginger on
everything you know might what it was
that's like the that's the game changer
this was okay the chicken teriyaki thing
that was like I could skip on that but
like everything else was really solid in
a shrimp his friend was like okay but
everything else was like pretty good
roast we're kind of hard not to give him
to Tokyo because it was made here like
this in the original place where it was
made and there's so many good options
everything seems so authentic even
though it's fast food so ya tebya this
one in Tokyo so I'm gonna finish this up
it's early morning I need some cool and
I didn't know how extra calorie for this
stuff yes
[Applause]
[Music]